Nichts ist lästiger als ein leerer
akku
Und so tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit an innovativen ideen um uns das nervige problem endlich für immer abzunehmen und jetzt ist es wohl tatsächlich
soweit ein forschungsteam
Des samsung ex1 institute of technology hat die grundlage für einen neuartigen akku entwickelt
der in phänomenal kurzen zwölf minuten voll geladen werden kann das geheimnis dieses technischen traums graffy
wie genau dieser
Akku funktioniert und ob er tatsächlich schon bald die
althergebrachten lithium ionen batterien ersetzen wird jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wird unser traum von einer langen akkulaufzeit
kombiniert mit einer kurzen ladezeit jetzt schon bald tatsächlich realität
Wenn man samsung glauben mag dann ja die neu
entwickelten batterien des unternehmens laden in der theorie nach eigenen angaben wohl bis zu fünfmal schneller als die herkömmlichen
lithium-ionen-akkus
Als basis dafür dient graf in dieser stoff gilt schon länger als allzweckwaffe technische träume aller art wort
zu machen
Im detail besteht es aus einer einzigen transparenten schicht aus kohlenstoffatom diese sind ähnlich angeordnet wie bienenwaben
Dadurch verein trafen mehrere wirklich krasse eigenschaften es ist das wohl dünnste
Material der welt bis zu 300 mal fester als stahl härter als diamant dabei aber flexibel und leitfähiger als kupfer
Wahnsinn vor 13 jahren hat ein forschungsteam aus manchester
erstmalig eine anatomische lage graphen hergestellt für ihre arbeit bekamen die beiden
Wissenschaftler 2010 dem nobelpreis für physik und so hatte man. Graphen aufgrund seiner zahlreichen
superlativ eigenschaften schon länger als geeigneten kandidaten für die herstellung von batterien auf dem schirm doch es nutzbar für
praktische technologien zu machen das war bisher nicht gelungen der knackpunkt seine herstellung in großen mengen und das zu einem vernünftigen preis
Doch das ist jetzt offensichtlich gelungen die samsung forschungsgruppe aus südkorea hat das material nach eigenen angaben aus einem
günstigen material nämlich
siliziumdioxid synthetisiert dazu der beteiligte projektleiter sonne in lluc und ist es gelungen
Und werkstoff mit graphen in großen mengen zu einem erschwinglichen preis herzustellen
Bei, der produktion erinnern die vielen kleinen graffin bälle ein wenig an popcorn die werden dann in lithium ionen
Akku sowohl an der kathode als auch an der anode verwendet und erhöhen deren ladegeschwindigkeit. Um das
Im detail zu verstehen bei uns ein bisschen chemie die kohlenstoffatome in grafing sitzen jeweils auf den ecken von
regelmäßig angeordneten sechsecken die atome wechselwirken ihre elektrischen felder
überlagert sich das verhalten der elektronen führt dann dazu dass strom
1,5 mal besser geleitet wird als es bei kupfer der fall ist denn die
kohlenstoffatome in graphen sorgen dafür dass sich die ladungsträger quasi masse los für
Die versprechen aus südkorea sind kaum zu glauben an graf in accum könne demnach in nur zwölf minuten voll geladen werden zudem sei auch seine
Kapazität, im vergleich zu den herkömmlichen
lithium-ionen-akkus größer und zwar um knapp die hälfte also genauer um 45 prozent
diese höhere energiedichte führt also letztendlich dazu dass mehr energie
auf kleinem raum gespeichert werden kann doch die samsung forschungsgruppe
Relativiert ihr ergebnis gleich wieder ein wenig bis die neuen akkus in industriellem stil hergestellt werden können werden wohl noch
einige jahre vergehen dennoch ist das jetzt ein riesenschritt in der akkutechnologie
denen sich wohl auch viele andere industriezweige nutzbar machen werden zum beispiel
Könnten grafen bälle bei der konstruktion von elektroautos helfen da sie extrem
temperatur stabil sind samsung wittert hier zu recht ein riesiges geschäft
Das unternehmen hat bereits patente in südkorea und den usa für seine herstellung der kaffee in belle
Angemeldet wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem
Genau auf die sache nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert wie geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Revolution super akkus erfunden ja eine andere sensationelle entwicklung in der akkutechnologie ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran